yeah hello and welcome to this video
which is something that I have not done
for quite a while it's a book review and
down essentially it's um a book and
different format it's not a classical
book on paper even though you can buy
that book as a traditional paper book I
want to especially review a new version
of the book and the book is I mean you
already see it because I have it on the
right-hand side here on the screen
castles they are BR 100 M games you must
know this is basically the end game book
that I am recommend to absolutely all of
my students basically regardless of
their playing strength it's something
that absolutely every chess player
should I mean maybe not Magnus but now
that this current level but every
process player should should get go
through and yeah benefit from those
basic endgame knowledge what the data he
has done is he selected exactly 100 end
games that he thinks young that they are
essential for you as a player it's a
very practical selection there is
nothing obscure in there that you will
never get on the board with rather the
things that actually met and practical
plain now after let's focus I think out
for more than 10 years after this this
time now it is available untestable and
I have to say that I absolutely am
thrilled to show it how it works on that
learning platform because it's really
really really great let's have a look
how this works the thing is if you have
a traditional paper book um I mean I
always tell my students you know here
there are 100 end games and you can
easily make a program for yourself out
of that yeah just like every single week
take two positions learn them after one
year your end game knowledge for basic
and game
would be fantastic I mean really
fantastic if you learn them not just
like look at the book and say oh that's
good and then put it away but really you
know actively study them and on chess
about you have this let them go right in
down on chess about you actually yeah
learn it for real every single position
yeah and the the software ask you the
website is asking you those questions
what is your move and you're either they
got it right or you don't
and it yeah is a fantastic way of
tracking your progress
you make sure that you absolutely see
every single position and every single
critical situation but you need some
knowledge so I want to show right from
the beginning how that works on the
chess table platform so what I did is I
before I started the video I looked
through it a little bit but then I
completely reset to my progress so I'm
starting very basically but it doesn't
matter just I just want to show you how
it works so this won't be exactly
challenging but that's not the point I
want to show how it does work here on
that platform so um yeah it starts with
basic endings um jump King and pawn very
simple stuff you can use you can read
the same text as it is in the book and
you are guided here yeah okay so we will
be done reading and now it guides you
through the through the positions again
this is not yet part of the 100 but
rather an intro section like okay this
is even more basic than the 100 yeah
and it starts with very simple things
like this can the pawn promote without
the aid of the king yeah everybody knows
so the rule of the square basically
and okay we are playing white what
should we do a for after the pawn
advances we draw an imaginary square
that reaches the eighth rank in this
example the vertices of the square are
yeah a 4 to a 4 to a 8 does this way to
e8 to e4 and now what should you search
what should we play
okay we go in for and we go in 10 points
and it shows the square this is really
nice and there's a some assistance there
yeah black goes King f7 trying to catch
it and the text you can read on the left
hand side and then now what should we do
it headed it it was shown before so we
have to push the pawn and we see that we
simply push the pawn to promotion
Queen Queen is correct and now it you
get asked the whole sequence again of
course here it is extremely basic but
you get the idea and you have to really
understand it move by move and go
through it okay okay so no next let's go
learn next
aha the black King has clearly reached
the square yeah obviously and with the
b-pawn we go with the people in here and
sorry the black king is definitely am
reaching the promotion square the pawn
can promote only with the aid of the
king is ways of blocking the enemy Kings
way now and you
read the text and the movies King to c7
followed by preventing King CH for the
King b8
so the king is blocking the blacks Kings
on their path to the promotion square so
we now have to remember it was King c7
otherwise black gets king dude so we're
going to do that and after King e6 we
already have controlled every square we
need and to be pawn can be pushed as SS
also on the texture and ok we go before
okay five and now again every push
before what's wrong I didn't pay
attention I mean okay it actually does
win as well but this is the more
consistent way and now we just going to
do it and promote it
I made a mistake though yeah you saw
there higher I was to click them okay so
let's go on next one what is the next
one I am now with it's about the
opposition you see very basic but I mean
yeah there might be people around who
don't know that it's easy to do you can
also skip that and if you want to when
you say okay the intro that is I know
then you just go on and start with the
next chapter
um yeah again you have the you have the
text and here we go f7 okay then King g7
to promote the pawn so f7 King g7 to
promote it yep and we've earn points
next one
hi now you see we have the colors we're
playing black and again you can read the
text okay a black has to go King g8
getting the opposition and after 17 f8
yep we have to stop the pawn of course
play black ayah again okay and we
lowered the opposition with the pawn on
the six right okay and our next yeah
power is on the sixth rank what what do
we have here King a six then we need to
get the opposition so King 86 yeah Keith
v6 so c7 squared here the pawn will
promote next they can we do the whole
sequence and done okay so I have gone
through a couple of examples and now we
can have a look at the books I know
actually not there I'm sorry I should do
it differently it's here right yeah so
we have the basic endings then we have a
test for the basic endings and then we
have a couple of couple of chapters that
comprise the 100 endings so if we
actually go and let's say Queen were the
spawn I'm just going there and this is
ending 16 number 16 and can we do that
we can jump right in there right
Queen will despawn okay
okay so we can I don't want to read out
the whole texture there's always an the
text to explain what's going on and then
our move is screening from the Queen
approaches to porn okay in fact in this
position and then basically every move
would win you cannot spoil it but this
is the right way to do it yeah Queen g3
to force the King back Queen f3 so that
the king has to go in front of the pot
this is always the key idea the moment
the king has to stop his own power
hamper is on point
we actually advance with the king I
think I just for trying out I mean every
King move here would make sense king f7
is just as good yeah try again or
towards an alternative so it is not
terrible or this yeah only King g7 this
is giving you the ten points but it
shows that when there's alternative then
it is that what you did is really just
as good okay um so here yeah we this is
making a lot of sense kingdoms back and
with the check before them till you won
again and again King g6 the animals
would be alternatives oh yeah the check
we approach this again the King comes
closer oh this actually
that's its major not necessary but it's
finally after to have that has the mains
with the video with the Queen I know we
have to do the whole procedure I'm not
probably failing I think going to do it
right there are this more than one way
to basically to do it but this is
totally really the quickest down this is
extremely quick because we have delayed
down yeah very nice again no that's the
lot I don't know why I just to do it
again there are some some settings in
playing that maybe you can change that
they don't have to do again it actually
I think makes some sense to to repeat it
so so it really gets second nature what
you do then yeah and to meet at the end
so very nice let's do one thing though I
do know next and I want to show you
something and goddesses to the h pond
okay we we are we are why generate eg8
going for promotion yeah and now other
thing is that King h8 is doing doing
stalemate I want to do one thing King h8
is of course very obvious because we
have to keep the pole one also I just
want to make a mistake to show you how
that works
incorrect book moves King edge aid okay
so I'm just going to just make make
mistakes and alright okay so yeah wait
let go here okay
incorrect yeah I'm okay this is very
stupid what I'm doing I just want to
show what happens if you if you're
really not getting it right I've made a
couple of mistakes though right so if I
am go back let's do where so have you
I'm not really I wanted to go to review
right where's review yes ready and here
we also review to show to to go to the
mistakes a spaced repetition okay didn't
want to do that
now you can actually it will ask you
again and again if you make make
mistakes I'm just not finding the menu
and it's what's that one we looked at
that I have some information at once now
what I was trying to say is it will
definitely it will ask you again if you
make make mistakes and in a certain in a
certain position it will definitely
bring this up again do I need to go over
study no nothing to study that the one
that I screwed up affected it was the
one that I screwed up and it will again
it will ask you again if you have a
mistake that you continuously make
what's really great is if we go back let
here with the here with a symbol that
let's get green the bomb you see how
much you have studied so if you get to
the point that you have everything green
then you really know I flipped at
everything this is really really great
and again if you make mistakes it will
ask you you are next give you four
spaced repetition this is something new
where I don't look at the platform like
on a daily basis but they continuously
adds new features um yeah I think it's
clear what it is doing and showing you
everything like yeah again and again
what about Luke trust porn where this
hook is that something that we can look
at with later position analysis number
52 we are
if I say learn next does it go with the
Philadelphia hire yeah we are we are
playing black here we go into the sixth
rank and there are a couple of a couple
of texts to to illustrate so okay okay
that was this one would be six seven and
the moment the pawn pushes we go back
onto the first rank if you go here for
exercise also draw here and it should
say alternative yeah so it is not
entirely wrong it is just not as correct
now it's gray it is also correct it is
not the single move that the site wants
to have and it's usually there is some
point behind it for example like here it
is usually correct to go as far as
possible here this really doesn't matter
but usually if you want to that say give
checks from the back you go into the
first rank because the just usually the
more comfortable way of doing this dr.
Freiden hack
oh yeah
and so um this is always done and now we
have all the chicks check from the back
of course yeah so we fill it up position
you maybe know if not this is the book
for you and I think it's excellent value
um I actually have one liquid study
Maria as I owned a book it was given to
me to do the revenue and the um I don't
actually know what the selling car the
price and I have no idea okay I don't
know maybe I can find it out if I
actually log out yeah probably I
probably can find it out with $14.99
it's currently still on a sale so this
is actually really really worth it the
the actual paper book I think is more
expensive I'm kind of I'm almost sure
let me just check it briefly to to see
quite 2295 in Euros Wow okay yeah so
this is actually this is a co-relation
1515 yeah um and yeah don't
underestimate um how much actual value
that has I mean it is those 100 endings
if you really know all of them can log
in again and if you really know the 110
you're really really really really good
at basic endings I mean fantastically
good better than me probably I don't
think I know on all 100 yeah
it's actually very very likely that I'm
below below that one
I've studied somebody's getting was good
but some are and some were I think some
I don't know
yes detail as they are described in the
book yeah I hope you enjoyed this review
this overview of the 100 any things you
must know I mean as I said I recommend
this to all of my students and now I
would definitely recommend ya recommend
them to get the chasuble version I think
it's just better yeah for for learning
it of course I mean if you have hand on
paper books this is an option but it's
it's it's more expensive and I think in
order to really ensure that you learn
everything then the platform here SEM is
really really great and also I can add
that I'm also working and chasuble
content when opening things then I'm
aiming for release in the next two
months so I can look look forward to
that as well yeah I hope you enjoyed the
overview of the 100 and games you must
know make sure to to learn to check I
don't know how long the sabers or let me
let me check that go this is really a
steel yeah if you can get it for $14.99
July 26 so it's so for for three days so
I'll you still can get it you know can
can get it cheap I am yeah again my my
full recommendation for this product
yeah thanks for watching the video I'll
be back soon with the live shows and so
on thanks for watching bye bye